[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Eric BT bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes député renaissance
de loise et vous avez été chargé par
Emmanuel Macron d'une mission sur la
décentralisation dont on va évidemment
parler on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview partenariat
avec la presse régionale représenté par
Julien lescuyet de la VO du Nord bonjour
Julien bonjour Orian bonjour monsieur
bonjour d'abord difficile de ne pas
parler de cette colère agricole Eric
vert qui s'étend les blocages qui se
poursuivent dans le pays est-ce que
l'exécutif échoue à étendre cette colère
agricole écoutez c'est une colère qui
qui qui dure parce que parce qu'elle est
sans doute profonde et qu'elle est elle
est euh entretenue par une série de
revendication qui pour la plupart sont
très légitimes et que don que l'État a
déjà pris en compte c'est ça qui est le
plus euh le plus difficile dans cette
dans cette affaire il y a des choses de
court terme il y a des choses de court
terme il y a des choses de de moyen
terme les agriculteurs d'ailleurs le
disent bien ils connaissent bien ces ces
sujets il des problèmes de de revenu le
problème du gazol le le le problème des
surtransposition le problème des la
réciprocité dans les accords
internationaux tout ça ne traite pas de
la même manière l'État a pris les chos
il faut faire plus mais il faut faire
bien il faut faire bien il faut d'abord
d'abord il faut aussi protéger nos
exportations donc dans les app dans les
les accords internationaux il y a
évidemment l'idée d'une de de la
réciprocité elle est extrêmement
importante mais aussi l'idée que c'est
positif aussi pour l'agriculture parce
qu'on exporte beaucoup donc il faut
faire très attention au mesure de
rétorsion si on place mal une
négociation à un moment donné dans un
accord c'est des accords qui prennent 10
ans 15 ans parfis comment vous jugez
justement la la position de la de de de
l'Union européenne il y a une sorte de
de camouflé de la part d'un commissaire
européen qui a dit qu'il était question
de de de jeter à la poubelle le le
travail autour du du Mercosur or du côté
de l'État français on dit qu'il faut
arrêter les négociations on a
l'impression qu'on est entre deux o et
que finalement la voix de la France
n'est pas tellement écoutée bah elle
elle va l'être le président de la
République est aujourd'hui à Bruxelles
l'État a toujours porté des mesure de
protection de l'agriculture française et
de l'agriculture d'ailleurs européenne
mais ce qui va peser au niveau européen
oui mais enfin derrière tous ces accords
je dire il faut c'est c'est quasiment
parfois 15 ans de travail donc c'est
compliqué de rentrer dans le détail
comme on rentre personne ne rentre dans
le détail en fait en dehors d'un certain
nombre de spécialistes très bien il y a
y a des vues des visions générales on a
l'impression qu'on importe énormément et
qu'au fond on tue les exportation
française et que on tue la compétitivité
de l'agriculture française parfois c'est
vrai en parfois c'est pas vrai du
tout regardez souvent parce que c'est
pratique regardez sur le sur le l'accord
avec le le Canada en ce qui concerne
l'importation de viande canadienne ce
qui avait été prédit comme une
catastrophe absolue ne l' pas ne l'est
pas ne l'est pas et au contraire c'était
plutôt positif pour l'agriculture
française après c'est difficile de le
dire à chacun selon les secteurs selon
la taille des exploitations il y a plein
il y a y a des agriculteurs qui vont
très mal qui travaille beaucoup qui sont
pas payés enfin tout ça tout ça c'est
évidemment
extraordinairement ça veut dire que
Paris le gouvernement il prend ce
gouvernement le prend totalement enfin à
brascore il y aura des propositions de
de moyen terme il y aura des propos il y
a eu des propositions de court terme que
le premier ministre a déjà évoqué quand
il revient sur la sur l'augmentation de
ce qu'on appelle le gazol non routier
c'està-dire au fond la la baisse du prix
de du du diesel pour les pour les
agriculteurs bon il prend en compte
quelque chose qui peut pourrait sembler
comme contradictoire il y a une erreur
il y a une erreur de la part de de
Gouvernement sur ce écoutez il y avait
il y avait un accord il je veux dire il
il y avait un accord il y avait un
accord euh sur le fait que pendant euh
plusieurs années euh on augmente
doucement euh le le le gazol et qui est
des contreparties c'est-à-dire que les
les sommes économisées d'une certaine
manière par euh par l'État revenait euh
aux agriculteurs donc il y avait un
accord com a qui aujourd'ui app au
blocage est-ce qu'il font preuve
d'ronsabilité mais non moi je je surtout
pas jeter de l'huile sur le feu et et
dire cela les agriculteurs sont
organisés heureusement et la FNSA est un
très grand syndicat donc là la question
n'est pas là et plutôt responsable et
plutôtf M le mouvement leur échappe un
petit peu parce que la base ça vient de
la base et FN a suivi en réalité je sais
pas si ça leur échappe je vois
simplement que ils sont quand même au
premier plan làdessus ce qui peut
échapper c'est c'est quand des
agriculteurs veulent
venir envahir le le
r quand on veut envahir ringisme bah le
pays ministre de l'Intérieur le
gouvernement il a bien raison mais des
lignes rouges dit non ça c'est c'est pas
possible donc donc ça pas été possible
et et tant mieux il y a une peur de la
radicalisation de ce mouvement il y a
une peur de il y a une peur partout il y
a toujours des peurs de radicalisation
dans le monde où on vit on l'a vu avec
les gilets
jaunes on l' vu à d'autres moments on le
voit dans les urnes des partis très
radicaux ont beaucoup de sièges à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui des
deux côtés à droite comme à gauche et
éid les doutes qu'a qu'a évoqué le
Premier ministre dans sa discussion de
dans sa déclaration de politique
générale ils sont là partout pourquoi
parce qu'on est dans un monde qui change
beaucoup et qui change très vite et
l'agriculture elle est au premier rang
puisqu'elle est à la fois entre la la
nécessité de protéger l'écologie
agriculteurs sont des écologistes hein
c'est les premiers au contact de la
nature donc ils veulent pas ils vont ils
veulent pas dégrader cette nature donc
on le on leur impose des choses en
général qu'ils font il faut juste qu'on
en mesure bien à un moment donné
l'équilibre et ça c'est très important
et que notamment à l'intérieur de
l'Europe l'affaire des surtranspositions
elle est elle est absolument
fondamentale et beaucoupi je je suis
content que le gouvernement a pris des
engagements par la voie de de Gabriel
Atal il faut juste qu'on puisse les
respecter c'est pas la première fois
qu'on parle des surtransposition
vraiment pas la première fois ce sujet
il avait été parfaitement diagnostiqué
il faut queétat s'empêche de de de
surtransposer de surtransposer alors
quand il y a une Cride on arrête tout et
puis après la vie reprend son cours et
c'est ça qu'il ne faut pas faire il faut
pas que la vie reprenne son cours comme
avant il faut pas qu'on oublie ça il
faut que ce soit clairement gravé dans
les intentions de la République Julien
on va parler du discours de politique
générale de gabrielal oui de discours de
politique générale qui a beaucoup fait
parler évidemment des commentateurs ont
pointé un catalogue de mesures que
n'aurait pas renié Nicolas Sarkozi vous
qui avez été l'un de ses ministres
est-ce que vous valider ben moi je
valide que c'était un très bon discours
de politique générale euh j' pas ma
question j'en ai entendu bah si c'est
mes convictions vous pouvez vous
demander à quelqu'un
d'autou est-ce que c'est un discours que
n'aurait pas ré Nicolas il y a la valeur
travail euh y a évidemment l'autorité et
euh l'autorité partout au fond
l'autorité l'école l'autorité il y a un
grand passage sur la santé qui a était
je pense vraiment bienvenu même si là
aussi les réponses s'inscrivent parfois
dans le long terme ça veut dire qu'il
faut faire beaucoup de choses pour
essayer de regrouper les forces et
retrouver à ce qu'il a des médecins
devant des Français quoi quand il y a
des Français qui peuvent plus avoir de
médecin généraliste quand on voit l'état
des services des urgences un peu partout
dans notre dans notre pays c'est vrai
que ça interpelle et c'était
extraordinairementup continue de
s'interroger à savoir si elle doit
suivre la la voix de la motion de de de
censure est-ce que vous regrettez cette
cette réflexion mais de enfin encore une
fois enfin moi je devrait plutôt
s'interroger sur sur comment essayer
d'apporter des réponses au au français
plutôt que de savoir si on fait une
motion de censure ou pas une motion de
censure c'est de la mauvaise politique
c'est de la politique de de voilà de
bazar bazar à tous les sens du terme
c'est mettre le bazar la France elle a
pas besoin de ça encore une fois les
transformations auxquelles qu'on
affronte il y a assez peu de
gouvernements qui a eu à les affronter
complètement elle changeent la vie des
gens elle change notre vie elle change
la vie de nos téléspectateurs ils le
voient tous les jours donc ça crée des
doutes des inquiétudes mais ça crée
aussi une formidable opportunité et j'ai
trouvé que le premier ministre enfin
c'était un discours qui ne cachait rien
c'était pas un discours naïf c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire mais c'est un
discours qui trace des perspective qui
dit les choses qui donneent des espoirs
qui donne envie donc on doit se battre
on doit faire des efforts les efforts
doivent être justement donne envie mais
qui qui qui trouve pas encore un écho
auprès des des Français je vais vous
citer un un sondage auodxa alors les
Français sont 73 % à approuver les six
principales mesures du discours de
politique générale de de Gabriel Atal
mais paradoxe 58 % disent ne pas avoir
été convaincu en fait ce qui pose
clairement la question de la crédibilité
de la parole politique mais personne
n'est jamais convaincu de rien vous
prenez tous les sondages à chaque fois
qu'un politique dit quelque chose c'est
c'est c'est plus de 50 % de non
convaincu donc
question bah ça pose question euh dans
une démocratie comme comme la comme la
France euh le le au fond la la critique
prend le dessus euh toujours si regardez
regardez le chômage il y a moins moins
de chômage même si c'est difficile euh
aujourd'hui puisque l'économie est
mondiale et a plutôt tendance à ralentir
mais il y a moins de chômage ça c'est un
fait euh il y a beaucoup de postes qui
trouvent pas de de preneur ça c'est un
fait bon bah le chômage c'est plus
c'était la priorité numéro 1 ça allait
plus euh et et et au fond c'est normal
Victo vou dire on regarde ce qui ne va
pas et comme il y a toujours plein de
trucs qui ne vont pas dans la vie
quotidienne comme dans la vie tout court
c'est c'est c'est une je pense que c'est
une attitude assez assez logique et
assez normale et d'ailleurs les les
dirigeant l'intègre il faut sans arrêt
améliorer et parfois c'est juste des
améliorations d'ajustement donc on fait
des on améliore les choses aujourd'hui
c'est pas tout à fait le cas c'est des
améliorationsuc
gabriqué il a parlé de la smicardisation
il a raison c'est une forme deationme de
de trappe de trappe à SMIC c'est dire
que les gens ils commencent au SMIC puis
au fond ils n'en sortent pas ça c'est
pas normal la progression des salaires
c'est fondamental et le modèle social
tel qu'il est construit tel qu'il est
construit çavait probablement beaucoup
d'intérêt à un moment donné aujourd'hui
c'est dangereux on a la tendance à
plutôt ralentir l'augmentation des
salair qu'au contraire l'avantager donc
on va parler du discours de Gabriel Atal
hier pardon devant les sénateurs où il a
été question de décentralisation je le
disais vous êtes chargé vous d'une
mission sur la décentralisation
gabrielal Julien qui a promis une loi
sur la décentralisation d'ici la fin de
l'année oui et évidemment c'est avec
votre travail qu'on imagine qu'il va
qu'il va va s'inspirer est-ce que vous
pouvez d'ors et déjà nous dire un peu
les pistes qui sur lesquelles vous
travaillez non on travaille sur les
c'est le président de la République
autour du mois de novembre on m'a chargé
d'une mission pour proposer une une
évolution de la décentralisation un
approfondissement de la décentralisation
aujourd'hui personne n'est content quand
vous faites le tour des grandes
associations d'élus euh on est pas
content les les les maires sont pas
contents euh la loi 3DS la lo 3DS a été
une dé desajustement c'est c'est c'est
une loi importante une bonne partie
d'ailleurs n'est pas appliquée au fond
les élus ne s'en saisissent pas bon donc
en tout cas mais ça veut dire que la loi
de la fin de l'année ce ne TR pas que
des ajustements ce sera une véritable
loi decentralisation c'est pas du tout
des ajustements c'est une loi
d'approfondissement de la
décentralisation ce serait ça une ou d
je ne sais pas on verra on n'est pas
encore à la fin de l'année et loin de
là on y travaille la forme juridique
j'en sais rien je le gouvernement verra
en fonction des propositions ce qui est
très très important c'est c'est au fond
d'améliorer la production du service
local la production du service local
c'est le service tel qu'il est produit
pour les concitoyens est-ce qu'il est
bien produit est-ce qu'il est mal
produit il faut regarder les questions
de moyens beaucoup d'élus se plaignent
euh de de de d'absence de de moyens euh
l'État leur dit mais des moyens on en a
donné beaucoup regardez pendant le covid
on a été l'assureur de tout on était
l'assureur des salariés l'assureur des
entreprises l'assureur des collectivités
euh locales donc il faut aussi regarder
ce qui relève en réalité de la libre
administration des collectivités locales
c'estàd non mais concrètement
concrètement ça veut dire quoi Eric vert
est-ce que ça veut dire parce que là
notamment les maires disent euh qu'ils
n'ont plus de de pouvoir fiscal euh avec
la suppression de la la taxe
d'habitation est-ce qu'il faut redonner
un impô fléché sur la libre la libre
administration ça veut dire que lorsque
vous êtes
responsable de d'une politique du la
mise en œuvre de l'organisation d'une
d'une politique so une politique sociale
ou d'urbanisme ou de sécurité lorsque
vous en êtes responsable et que l'État a
acté le fait que c'était pas lui qui
s'en occupait directement mais que
c'était vous commune intercommunalité
département ou ou région et bien alors
là lesl local il exerce à plein son
pouvoir il il il décide de
l'organisation de cette politique il
peut en décider d'ailleurs différemment
qu'on soit au nord ou au sud et puis
également il il
l'organise totalement donc ça c'est pas
complètement vrai ça ça veut dire un
nouvel impôt pour que les élus aient des
ressources propres alors il y a il y a
la question de la fiscalité la fin de la
taxe d'habitation elle a été actée elle
a été votée par l'Assemblée nationale et
par et par le Sénat bien sûr que non
enfin ce sera al ce serait le ce serait
le le le pompon de
l'impuissance politique vous décidez un
truc et puis 3 mois après un an après 2
ans après 3 ans après vous revenez vous
revenez là-dessus je pense que c'était
une mesure chacun au Sénat on en a
parler on
l' bah moi j'avais mon opinion de de
l'époque elle est clairement elle était
clairement affichée mais ça été fait
donc c'est moi j'ai un esprit
pragmatique on va pas passer son temps à
refaire euh ce qui a déjà été fait
élusulent de
laent de la clarté ou on peut réfléch
aussi autrement on peut réfléchir
autrement à l'évolution des finances
locales pour qu'il de l'économie on peut
réfléchir il y a des partages d'impôts
nationaux aujourd'hui la TVA est un
impôt qui est largement partagé par par
aux collectivités la télva l'État en
perçoit grosso modo moins de 50 %
aujourd'hui est-ce que on l'a fait de
manière consciente et cohérente non donc
est-ce qu'on peut remettre de la
cohérence sur tout cela et ça c'est très
important est-ce qu'on peut aussi
r est-ce qu'on peut aussi rattacher les
ressources locales à la nature des
charges qu'elles ont un département il a
beaucoup de charges sociales une une
région elle a beaucoup de de charges
dans le domaine de de
l'équipement des des
infrastructuresle une charge
infinancement c'est ça la clarté
normalement oui d'illeur le Premier
ministre l'a évoqué charge un
financement ou au moins un financement
qui qui a qui a un lien avec l'v de
cette charge et et qui ne soit PASAT
cyclique c'estàd qu'en même temps vous
voyez la baisse de vos recettes et une
augmentation de vos de vos de vos
dépenses c'est le cas par exemple pour
les départements quand ils ont des
droits de mutation bah ça s'effondre ça
a beaucoup augmenté hein mais en ce
moment ça baisse plutôt et et et en même
temps il VO le charg il voit les charges
de leur prestation sociales augmenter
ces charges de prestation sociale elles
sont par elles-même définies par l'État
et donc chacun doit être responsable de
ce qu'il choisit l'État doit être
responsable de l'égalité dev les citoyen
on peut pas verser un RSA différent au
Nord comme au Sud ni une prestation
compensatrice du handicap il faut le
faire donc l'État doit exercer cette
responsabilité et l'assumer et le
défendre et les les départements sont
chargés de la mise en œuvre de cette
position comment on fait pour que chacun
y voit le plus comment on fait pour
accroîre l'efficacité du service public
comment on fait pour redonner du sens à
la libre administration des
collectivités dans un État unitaire dans
un État unitaire dans un état qui a la
compétence de ces compétences c'est le
seul sur mais ça veut dire quoi est-ce
que c'est compatible avec la
différenciation oui bien sûr parce que
la différenciation elle elle réajuste
parfois l'inégalité entre les citoyens
le fait que vous ne soyez pas vous ne
viviez pas dans les mêmes conditions
dans le Nord et dans le sud dans l'Est
et dans l'Ouest et cetera qui a des
spécificités par bassin d'emploi qui a
des spécificités par région géographique
ou par identité il est assez naturel
qu'à un moment donné quand une règle
s'impose elle doit pouvoir s'imposer
doit pour y avoir une marge de manœuvre
c'est le droit de dérogation dont
parlait le Premier ministre oui il doit
y avoir une marge de manœuvre alors ça
veut pas dire que la loi elle doit être
différente partout parce qu'on va plus
rien comprendre il faut mettre un cadre
à tout ça mais il doit pouvoir y avoir
des marges de manœuvre tant dans la la
loi l'interprétation que peut en faire
les euh un préfet par exemple
lu alors plutôt la règle d'ailleurs règ
administrative que la que la lo mais le
législateur pourrait également fixer une
marge dans un certain nombre de
conditions pour certains pour certains
textes pour que ce soit clair pour que
ce soit au plus proche des besoins des
des Français il faut que la production
encore une fois on produit du service
public pardon de cette expression on
produit des choses on produit des
politiques on produit des et ce service
public il doit être le plus efficace
possible il doit être le plus simple
aussi simplicité dans dans l'action
simplicité dans dans l'administration
dans renvoit pas la responsabilité de
pas moi c'est l'é les Français n'
peuvent plus tes ordures ménagères c'est
pas moi le maire lui dit Monsieur le
Maire je comprends pas il ramasse plus
mais c'est pas moi c'est
l'intercommunalité l'intercommunalité
disent non non non il faut que les élus
prennent leur responsabilité en général
ils savent le faire mais pour qu'il le
fassent il faut que ce soit clairement
défini justement Emmanuel Macron
beaucoup parler du MIF territorial
Julien une question làdessus oui puisque
on a on a essayé de comprendre puisque
c'est vrai dans première lettre de
mission on avait Emmanuel Macron
semblait vouloir réduire le nombre de
strates décentralisé Gabriel ATA lui a
expliqué je cite vouloir dépasser les
bas stériles sur l'échelon à conserver
ou supprimer alors où est-ce qu'on va en
fait
le le le courrier qui m'était adressé il
il parlait effectivement de strat et de
ce que souhaitait dire le président de
la République CIT pas supprimer une une
state une strate elles existent on va
pas on va pas déclencher des
guerres
non il aura pas dans mes propositions je
suis pas je suis pas président c pas il
aura pas de
suppression il peut y avoir une mise en
ordre en meilleur ordre des différents
niveaux de strat et des responsabilité
qu' qu'elles exercent mais pas de
suppression non mais ça c'est su
départements ils ont eu peur de cela
jamais été l'intention de quiconque on
va pas supprimer des régions qui ont été
recréées augmenté on va pas supprimer
les communes enfin j'ai pas l'impression
qu'on est en
on peut inciter à ce qu'il y a des
communes në mais par le B du volontariat
euh on peut éclaircir le rôle entre
parce qu'il y a pas qu'une question de
entre l'État et les collectivités entre
les communes et les intercommunalités
c'est des histoires extrêmement
différentes selon les cas de figure que
des plus grandes de Lyon Marseille ou
Paris jusqu'au au plus petit la plus
petite des communautés de de communes
comment on fait pour que la subsidiarité
aussi le fait queon puisse agir au bon
niveau comment on peut y arriver la loi
d'ailleurs
3DS pardon de de C c'est terrible nom
cette cette loi là elle elle permettait
de d'adapter les choses bon ça a pas
très bien marché parce que les élus ne
s'en sont pas saisis par contre en face
de tout cela et le Premier ministre l'a
dit hier il doit y avoir plus de
déconcent de déconcentration des
services de l'État c'est plus de de
pouvoir à l'état local et pas aux
administrations centrales donc
l'augmentation du pouvoir du préfet elle
est fondamentale làdedans si vous
augmentez vous approfondissez la
décentral
il faut en face de cette
décentralisation que l'État lui-même
s'organise mieux et le préfet bah le
préfet il est évidemment au cœur de
Monsieur je réitère ma question pas de
suppression de de strat mais est-ce que
le grand projet de Nicolas Sarkozi du
conseiller territorial pourrait renaître
à l'occasion de votre mission en tout
cas on va le regarder évidemment parce
que c'est un sujet dont on parle depuis
maintenant plus de 10 ans il avait été
voté en 2010 supprimé après par François
hand donc mais c'est resté dans le débat
politique donc tout ce qui reste dans le
débat politique faut tenter à un moment
donné de le de le purger on va pas en
parler pendant
intéresse just c'est de le purger en
fermant la porte ou c'est de le purger
en leant pas d'opinion parce que cette
mission elle a commencé il a même pas de
mois donc on fera un premier premier
étape d'ici le le printemps et puis et
puis je rendrai des conclusions au
gouvernement d'ici le début du mois de
de mai le président du Sénat d'ailleurs
suit les choses de façon très étroite
d'ailleurs je salue le travail des
sénateurs sur ce
sujet bien entendu il y a moi je vais
pas refaire des travaux qui ont déjà été
faits enfin ça commence à à bien faire
de toujours refaire des des choses je je
prends les rapports qu'on estime les
meilleurs il y a eu beaucoup de travail
de de Mathieu d'Arnaud au Sénat de
Françoise Gattel au Sénat beaucoup de
travail de la délégation David Valence
par exemple au à l'Assemblée nationale
il y a un travail considérable il y a
des travaux en cours sur le statut de
l'élu violette pilebou et et Sébastien
jumelle il y a beaucoup de travail qui
est fait donc ces rapports ils ont était
souvent très approfondi bah il faut
regarder comment ils ils s'inscrivent
parfois ils vont jamais jusqu'au bout de
la proposition notamment dans le domaine
de la fiscalité local de la réforme on
fond des ressources locales comment
essayer d'avoir des des des des paniers
de ressources dans laquel il y a une
forme d'autonomie mais aussi qui soit le
plus garanti possible par rapport aux
crisees bon bah là on il y a pas non
plus pltor de de de proposition
opérationnelle détaillé et c'est c'est
évidemment là-dessus que que nous serons
j'espère j'espère qu'on a de bonnes
propositions et j'espère que ça fera
aussi consensus euh parce que l'idée
c'est c'est de c'est c'est d'améliorer
la décentralisation au fond de la
République française c'est une
République décentralisée c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est la Constitution donc si
on peut faire vivre si on peut donner du
sens à cela si on peut améliorer la
qualité du service public et faciliter
le travail des élus locaux d'ailleurs
Gabriel Atal a rendu hommage aux élus
hier devant devant le Sénat et ben on
aura on aura gagné et et ce sera ce sera
bien pour la France vous savez on dit
toujours faut libérer les énergies une
bonne partie des énergies elle est là
elles sont là hein faut juste soulever
soulever un peu la table beaucoup bloqué
par de la norme du poids de
l'simplification non l'État ne bloque
pas tout quand on rend hommage aux
policiers aux gendarmes quand on rend
hommage au personnel soignant quand on
on rend hommage on rend hommage au à
l'état d'une certaine manière c'est bien
l'état qui organise ses services public
et ben les élus locaux ils organisent le
service public local on doit leur rendre
hommage et on doit leur donner
évidemment les moyens de le faire dans
le cadre d'un État unitaire dans le
cadre d'un État unitaire nous ne sommes
pas un état
fédéralidement au gouvernement et à
l'état de de garantir l'égalité des
citoyens les libertés locales l'ordre et
cetera et un derni mot parce que parmi
les sujets d'inquiétude des élus locaux
il y a la question du zan du Zéro
artificialisation nette est-ce qu'il
faut assouplir ce dispositif en tout cas
on va très très loin dans ce domaine sur
le plan réglementaire je vois que là
maintenant et c'est tant mieux le le
nouveau gouvernement a pris en charge
l'affaire de la simplification c'est un
vieux sujet c'est un sujet aussi
compliqué que la complication est aussi
malheureusement peu simple et donc on on
le le Premier ministre va s'y atteler
moi je proposerai une augmentation du
pouvoir réglementaire des des élus
c'estàdire lorsqu'on a une compétence
bah on en définit l'organisation euh euh
donc oui il faut il faut il faut
absolument mais a une
une dérive de la loi que la loi elle est
de plus en plus bavarde pardon c'est
vrai à l'Assemblée c'est vrai au Sénat
il y des amendements dans tous les sens
la loi est de plus en plus bavarde
empiète de plus en plus sur le pouvoir
réglementaire de l'État l'État se
retrouve avec un texte qui va au-delà du
pouvoir législatif et le Conseil
constitutionnel devrait regarder ça
parfois de plus près et nous avons après
euh au fond il faut fa lo ch chacun
chacun le rôle de chacun il est déplacé
comme une sorte de cascade de la
complication euh et puis une fin
l'administration centrale qui devait
préciser les choses ça a déjà été
précisé dans la loi donc elle le reprise
encore elle elle reprécise encore plus
fortement et ça donne des trucs comme on
va réglementer le nombre de vélos dans
des rames dans des rames de train quoi
un dernier mot plus politique peut-être
é ce que vous nous dites vous rendrez
vos conclusions début mai ce sera à un
mois des européennes est-ce que votre
rapport il a aussi pour but d'apporter
des solutions aux élus d'apporter des
solutions aux gens et de contrer le
rassemblement national euh contre
personne enfin moi je suis contre le
rassemblement national et je le
combattrai
mais enfin la seule manière d'empêcher
les extrémisme de tout poil d'arriver au
pouvoir c'est pas de dire que ce sont
des extrémismes c'est pas de de c'est
c'est de r la seule manière
ça c'est plus audible donc je je je
pense que c'est par le résultat nous on
a est on doit être une république du
résultat et et et dans cette république
du résultat il y a les pouvoirs publics
le service public dans d'autres pays
c'est pas très important en France c'est
extrêmement important et ce service
public il doit être de qualité doit être
adapté au citoyen il un rôle fondamental
à jouer évidemment mais les
collectivités locales ont un rôle
extrêmement important on va essayer de
leur donner la possibilité de continuer
à le faire et c'est c'est c'est le
président de la République qui tient il
tient beaucoup merci r on espère que
vous viendrez nous présenter vos
résultats vos premières conclusions mais
bien sûr de toute façon les présentera
vous êes vous êtes le bienvenu pour le
faire chez nous merci
merci Julien la une de la voie du Nord
tracteur et blindé né anné aux pores de
Paris c'est à la Une de votre journal à
la semaine prochaine Julien on passe au
club de territoirees